yeah i'm going to give you a quick
rundown of my 10.
please i got freddie gibbs at one okay
i got conway at two so so far we're two
for two on our list
all right i'm with it benny at three
okay
we're three for three mozzie at four
so i i we got to start putting some
respect on mazzy's name man
i like mine you put out two great albums
this year
i like mozzie and he's like to me the
one guy
obviously he's from sacramento but like
when it comes to like the west coast
[ __ ] like
i feel like he is the guy who everybody
respects who you'll meet
as as a rapper too so i got mozzie high
on my list man
uh i'm not mad at that i got big sean at
five
i really enjoyed uh detroit too i really
enjoyed his presence on a lot of other
people's records obviously
full things with gibbs see we did uh we
have
big sean both at five then do we yeah
okay yeah
i have bookshawn at five things are
going to get real different than here
i got um i got royce the five nine of
six
okay and i don't think royce made your
list i didn't make i was thinking about
royce too but
what did it what prevented royce from
making the list is the fact that he put
out i liked allegory
but i also think if it wasn't for the
grammys that album would have been
forgotten about
and after allegory i don't think he
really did anything else throughout the
year he was kind of silent
yeah i mean he was on sean's album i
mean he also he also i mean look i also
go back to the eminem album
he gassed the m album he produced on the
m album yeah um
i'm gonna go killer mike at seven run
the jules four is is
is a an incredible album to me so i got
killer mic at seven
i'm at that i think oola is one of the
best rap songs of the year
walking on the snow is the one for me
man the one with gangsta boo on the hook
um another artist who's not on your list
i got busta rhymes at eight
really yeah man i really love yellie too
man
you like that album i really enjoyed it
bro i hated that album felt like
homework
you hated the album i hated it really
it was one it was too long and busted
just to me it just felt like it was
moments where he was spinning i liked
the record with him in rhapsody
but in totality the record the album
just felt like
he was just yelling and it felt like
just you know when you know
and you know when you're trying to enjoy
yourself with the club someone started
trying to pitch you yes
yo like yo all right i get to you later
i gotta mix take this out
like yeah i really enjoyed the bust
album i'm probably
i'm a lot higher on the bust of rhymes
than you are then i really enjoyed it
man
um oh okay i got russ at nine
okay and then i got a little baby at 10.
wow okay little baby is an
artist who i never ever thought would
make this list in in my entire life
based on like it being called the best
rappers
but man if he didn't have
a hell of a year uh and you know
but he also probably gets most improved
of the year too most improved player
oh yeah absolutely like little bait if
this we if we did a hottest
mc's list he'd probably be number one
two and three hottest yeah i think it's
like him pop smoke and uh
and probably righty rich and then and
and then you know you probably feeling
the baby and
and um who am i forgetting that would be
in that
i think megan would make that list maybe
uzi
yeah like that's a hot artist but uh
that's the hottest list which we used to
get pissed off about when mtv would do
conversation yeah he was on that panel
mm-hmm yeah yeah and um i remember
voting for drake and they voted for
kanye but
that was that that was like four years
ago yeah so some of my honorable
mentions
are um boldy james
okay foley's nice yeah he had a crazy
year
um i also of course
uh west side gun i think we have to
just salute his body of work for the
year
pray for paris that's that's that's on
the list i'll give you a scene
it's on my list too on the list yeah
it's pretty high on my list
um also i gotta i gotta show some love
to eminem i
actually thought eminem's album was uh
his best album in like 10 years
i really liked um recovery
i liked recovery a lot yeah but recovery
was
2 000 and was that that was the one with
like um he was like
walking down the road and [ __ ] that was
like 2010. yeah that was a long time ago
that was 2010 and since recovery really
it's been a whole lot of [ __ ]
shout out to eminem shout out to paul
rosenberg no i love eminem
he's one of my favorite rappers ever and
i feel like with with this album
i finally was like yes this is the
eminem
album that i've i've just wanted him to
make all the features
they didn't sound forced it was a step
in the right direction the intro i
remember
listening to that i thought that was
crazy you know so eminem that was
definitely i think
to your point it's probably his best
album in a while
he toned down the like forced ballads
with a
skyler gray and you know pink and
rihanna and
you know whoever the hell he was like
bro if i when when when the track
listening came out and i saw her name on
the track
i lost my [ __ ] mind i was like guys
will someone tell eminem to stop putting
this [ __ ] girl on records
i've been listening to the the b-side
that came out uh at nine o'clock last
night but nonetheless yeah i
think you know you gotta throw eminem in
the honorable mention nah it's an
honorable mention
jay elect in the honorable mention i
hope kind of watched him on that album
but you know
um you know shout out to jay electronica
but yeah i think i think
how about this for the year do you think
this was like i feel like this is
one of the best years in recent memory
as far as like
just the quality of music we got oh
absolutely i think there was a lot of
great moments a lot of great music that
came out and
a lot of it probably just didn't get the
exposure it deserved but
if you were a rap fan you know where to
find the good [ __ ] man like there was
great music all around the board